Marc Scott Zicree, Screenwriter/Author: It holds
up because it's not about something trivial,
The Twilight Zone is about
something profound, deeply profound.
Film Courage:
What makes The Twilight Zone different
from everything else quality it's good okay
The Twilight Zone is possibly the
best television show ever made
I think there's an argument argument that
can be made for that Rod Serling never
wanted to be a science fiction writer he wanted
basically to be the Arthur Miller of television
and when he was censored when he couldn't write
about politics when he couldn't write about race
there were so many things he wanted to write
about and the censors just would not allow it
and his work he felt his work was
being turned into meaningless crap
because of these limitations he thought well if I
do science fiction maybe I can slide these things
past and they won't notice what I'm actually
doing and that that's worked it worked exactly he
he ended up writing four pilot scripts for
The Twilight Zone before the show got greenlit
he was very determined to to have that happen
and so I think it came from the fact that this
was a man who had a lot to say and knew how
to say it twilight zone just isn't about the
gimmick the gimmicks are great and the twist
endings and all of those things are wonderful
and the fact that it was science fiction and
horror and fantasy allowed it to be universal
in a way that had he just been writing about
Medgar Evers or something it wouldn't have been
because then it would seem very dated and the
writers from that era of live television generally
are not well known Tad Mosel or Reginald Rose
or even Paddy Chayefsky had Serling stayed in
live tv and not created The Twilight Zone
and he'd probably be forgotten now as good
as Requiem for Heavy Weight was or Patterns but
because he was forced to write in this wonderful
genre and write on universal themes
fear alienation loss of identity
it just created these amazing stories and
his scripts are so good that they would get
the top actors actors who often wouldn't do
television and and you got Bernard Herrmann and
Jerry Goldsmith these amazing composers and George
Clemons this phenomenal cinematographer it's just
you look at the best episodes of The
Twilight Zone and there are a lot of them
and you're just you hold your breath they're
so beautiful in every way and timeless and and
they work and even when what the story is you're
moved by these people because Rod had a genuine
sympathy and empathy for the little guy for
someone working in as a bank teller or a woman
who's a secretary or he's not writing generally
about presidents or kings or wealthy people
he doesn't even though he himself was one
of the best paid writers in television
he's not fawning he doesn't idolize
the rich like some writers have
he's some he's a regular guy he's a he's you
can get the sense that he has this big heart
he really cares deeply and he's coming from the
heart and again when I was talking a few minutes
ago about authenticity Rod when you see Rod
Serling on television he's exactly that guy I mean
I've seen videos of him teaching classes where
he wasn't he knew these wouldn't be broadcast
and he was absolutely himself warm and funny
and smart and and caring and and that really
comes across on twilight zone this is a man
saying here's a story I want to tell and I'm
sharing it with you or here's these other writers
that I've brought aboard who have these wonderful
stories to share with you it's his gift to the
audience and it holds up because it's not about
something trivial The Twilight Zone is about
something profound deeply profound and its
meaning conveys to the younger generation as much
as to the audience it was made for back in 1959.
have you seen every episode oh yeah okay what
would you say the top five I've actually when
I when I started writing The Twilight Zone it
was two year twilight zone companion it was two
years after rod's death and Carol Serling his
widow was still living in the house in Pacific
Palisades his dog was there this Irish Setter
and all these everything was exactly as he'd
left there was one room that was just the awards
the six Emmys and the peabody awards and on and on
and so in the garage there were film cans his film
cans of twilight zone episode 16 millimeter prints
it was part of his contract that he would get two
prints of every episode because there's no VCRs
there was no home recording back then so often
I would go home with a stack of these film cans
and put them on the projector and they had the
original commercials in the original coming
attraction spots and many of these had never
even been put through a projector they were just
pristine they were gorgeous and so yeah and there
were four episodes that weren't in syndication
and then there was an a season and 18 episodes
that were hour-long episodes that weren't
generally syndicated they every now and then
they'd pop up but yeah I had to do a little bit of
pursuing some of these episodes that were
not in the in the general audience though
one of the funniest stories in that regard
was that I was researching The Twilight Zone
companion and this was just as VCRs were
starting to become available for purchase
but they weren't widely available so I recorded
the episodes off the air on reels real tape I'm on
cassette tape and Rod didn't have copies of every
episode it got more and more hit and miss as the
seasons went on and so at one point they were like
I think two episodes that I could just not two or
three episodes that they just never aired on KTLA
[an Los Angeles television network] so which was
syndicating twilight zone so I called the station
manager and I said listen I'm doing a book on on
The Twilight Zone and I there's three episodes
I need to see and I want to find out when you're
going to be airing them because I really need
to see them he said well which episodes are they
and I told him he said well we'll broadcast
them next week so all of la watched the episodes
just because I needed to see them oh wow I thought
he was going to just have me in and maybe screen
them for me but nope everybody got to see him and
so that was that was really funny and wonderful
but but it was great that I was able to do to
produce the blu-ray set and do 52 commentaries and
and now of course I'm going to do the the rest of
them 104 that are left and so people will be able
to buy buy all of them so they'll be able to hear
everything I know about The Twilight Zone and for
all of the episodes it's gonna be great fun if you
had to choose what would be the top five I love
walking distance which was rod's personal favorite
it's about a man who goes back in time to his own
childhood it's a wonderful episode On Thursday
We Leave For Home which is a great episode that
Rod wrote with James Whitmore it's one of the hour
ones I have the I the beholder which is the woman
whose head is wrapped in bandages waiting to
see if she's been made to look normal nightmare
twenty thousand feet which is the Gremlin on The
Wing with William Shatner that Richard Donner
directed it's a great episode I mean I could
I could list 20. I mean and it's a good life
with billy mummy that's a great one where he's
got the power to do to terrorize a small town
but again I could easily pick death ship miniature
there's so there's so so many in praise of pip
there's just it just goes on and on time of the
last with Burgess Meredith as The Last Man on
Earth there's just I mean week after week after
week after week it was an astonishing artistic
feat what he was what he was pulling off it was
no one has ever really equaled it I don't think
I mean I've been very, very lucky
because I met Elaine [Zicree] when I was
I think I just turned 20 and so that was
perfection that was great because again when she
met me I was just a little college student there
was no telling if I would accomplish anything
and she had faith in me so I mean when I
met her I already knew she was wonderful
but she was taking a big risk in me and it
worked out but but I've been very lucky because
think of all the people who as kids they want
to be writers or directors or or producers they
watch tv shows they say god i'd like to be part of
that world I want to be on the other side of the
glass of the tv screen and I got to do that I
got to be that I mean my heroes were Rod Serling
and Ray Bradbury because they were doing tv and
books and movies and I got to do all of that.